Sitting on the same football field,
and I made a quilt.
Okay.
There's some people call concert versus
I called the confidence.
I said that I might be the greatest
player that ever woke up out of the
University of mine.
I did not say that because I thought I
was better than everybody else.
I see it there simply because I was
willing to put into work to now be back
here 18 years later,
my asking nobody for nothing today I'm
not.
I'm just sharing my story to tell y'all
every time you'd think somebody got a
good man and always good
as you guys said in man,
I sat around the greatest athletes in
the world.
There's no other man out there willing
to give up what I'm willing to give up.
I said that in 1993 when I said I wanted
to be degraded as hurricane and the only
thing that I got in the middle of all of
that,
this is the only thing in the father's
work,
this results,
there's no other blue.
I ain't got no other secrets to tell
y'all.
I ain't come here with nothing else but
to tell you if you want to do something
for
you,
want a better relationship with God,
there's not a person on my team is 16
years that is consistently beat me to
the ball every play.
Then again going to do a town
as it's got everything to do with
effort.
Nothing else.
15 straight years,
12 four bowls late.
And the only thing that's kept me around
as much effort.
So when you put on this all I ever knew,
what's the effort we'll get me scene,
I won't take efforts will get me noticed
to get to the league effort to one day
take care of my mom and my key effort,
which is which one you and
nobody else can give you their
efforts with the side.
And I'm still granted because the next,
let's talk about begin to all keep
watching me.
If I ain't
nobody ain't got convinced me of what I
do,
I'd do what I do because I do what I do.
Focus on heal from some
unmanned in creative.
Every one of you mean and here I have
that opportunity man.
But ask yourself the question,
personally,
I'm a Sam.
You really
question is,
what are you going to do with your time?
What drives,
you
know,
what you carry?
You carry a
legacy.
Greatness.
Greatness is a lot of small things done
when they after day,
workout after workout.
Obedience after will be the day
greatness as a lot of small things done
well.